[Musique]
son arrivée on va au rsa tout de suite
c'est donc le triple vinyle
la première saison de l'épopée
temporelle avec une illustration
magnifique de benfica
je suis trop heureux d'avoir un coffret
physique avec un triple vinyle collector
il ya très très peu de pièces pour vous
le procurer bien évidemment il suffit
d'aller sur narbonne.fr chaque
exemplaire est dédicacé vous allez me
dire oui mais cyprien j'ai pas de
lecteur vinyle mais ne vous inquiétez
pas il ya un code de téléchargement pour
télécharger la version numérique de
l'épopée temporelle pour écouter
absolument partout ils vous attendent ça
sera au pied du sapin peut-être je sais
pas je suis super content le point
culminant de les poupées temporel ça a
été la diffusion du dernier épisode dans
une salle de cinéma à paris c'était un
moment fou réunir si tous les comédiens
les fans toute l'équipe technique au
montage sont mille son enregistrement
composition des musiques présentes la
première heure sur les prêts temporaires
ainsi que françois descraques that into
you nous avons moyens sinon hauteur et
hitler fait de dictateur est donné au
coucher du soleil c'est quand on était
dans les studios lyonnais
tout ce monde là est grande
je lance coup ya à l'intérieur on voit
ici gignacois 18 heures merci fait là
aussi brillants aînés
c'est libérateur en fait de faire une
sérieuse atteinte rail super intéressant
tout la série maintenant sur sur la
chaîne youtube donc je vous invite à
aller coûte et si ce n'est pas déjà fait
voilà tu en parles de voyage dans le
temps des personnages un petit peu
débile toutes les formes de toutes les
tailles se font traverser les époques
pour une quête qui est retrouvé
l'inventeur de la machine à voyager dans
le temps qui disent non here is ok ce
que tu fais là quoi ben ali quand j'ai
eu l'idée de faire cette série je me
suis dit faudrait que je fasse avec des
comédiens professionnels des comédiens
de doublage et du coup j'ai rencontré
plein de comédiens et c'était exactement
ce que je voulais qu'ils ont participé
dont je suis content ya pas eu de
compromis aucun quand je te propose un
de faire un rôle de dauphin vas-y tu dis
oui il doit
bah oui oui oui je vais dédicaces et ce
à toutes les nations
mr et cléopâtre donc que dès que des
femmes voilà qui aime la chair est fêtée
gala concentre qui apparaît même
pression et où carey est à dix ans ça
les objets l'uma m et breeam
c'est là bas c'est juste la base le
challenge c'était de trouver des voies
qui ont la force qui ont l'émotion et
qui peuvent illustrer parfaitement et
personnages légendaires jousse avec des
voix donc du coup c'est des voix qui ont
du charisme
je viens de l'inventer peut-être
l'avez-vous iris elle est hyper sympa la
peur de rien elle est juste un petit peu
froid dans ses rapports amoureux avec
thomas mais une aventure qui vont vivre
ou peut-être changer tout ça bonjour
chers humain désolé mais d'une mais sert
à rien bon mon personnage est assez
sympa et c'est vrai que j'aurais eu des
fourmis d'en faire beaucoup plus mais
c'est pas dans son caractère puisqu'il
reste assez son sang il est très sobre
très simple mail offre la ventura un
looser ils ont incarné des personnages
incroyables ça m'a fait super plaisir
c'était très intimidant de jouer face à
veut d'ailleurs tout le monde a été
super pour une série audio moi je
m'estime vraiment comblé quelqu'un de
niacine maire d'auray je comprends mieux
pourquoi tu étais pas très emballé par
cette époque parce que c'est la guerre
veillon la zone de combat je voulais
collaborer aussi avec des illustrateurs
0 avoir cette base de série audio pour
que des gens puisse la mettre en image
par contre c'était important pour moi
qui ait pas un seul illustrateur je
voulais que tous les dessins et les
styles soit parsemé comme ça l'auditeur
il se dit eh ben moi je préfère cette
version là où l'on retient cette version
n'avait pas mal
l'audio permet de faire imaginer ce
qu'on veut la voix la saison une est
terminée elle existe maintenant en
vinyle
on peut penser à la suite quoi j'ai vécu
plein de choses c'était formidable
et merci d'avoir partagé ça avec moi en
l'écoutant deux ans vos retours et moi
je vous dis à très vite sur la chaîne
youtube jeudi 10 à 6
[Musique]